hey everyone this is Steve Electro with
collider and I'm thrilled to be with the
casting filmmakers behind biosphere at
our supper suite at the Toronto
International Film Festival you guys
were a surprise late addition to the
Fest was that on purpose what was it
being held like talk a little bit about
that would just like to be different
right yeah yeah we're just like we got
real contrary going through puberty and
we're just like held on to it for the
next 30 years no but how does that
actually work did they tell you we're
going to announce you late like is that
actually something that is discussed
yeah we we discussed it a lot actually
you know we we in our experience with
showing this film to audiences is one of
those movies the less you know about it
the better chance you have of enjoying
yourself and we kind of figured that out
early on and so when we talked with
Toronto about doing this movie you know
they were like well let's just let's
just do that then let's just kind of
bring it up and not tell them anything
yeah as a surprise screen so it's funny
because I wonder if you're going to be
doing I saw Palm Springs without knowing
anything going in and they were very
guarded and I didn't understand what I
was watching until all of a sudden it
hit well here's the thing Andy Samberg
is in this movie
um no but you know what I mean like they
hit they hid some key things are you
guys is it similar to that where there's
some big key things I don't think we're
hiding anything I think it's just you
know like Mark said it's
it plays better if you go and uh just
ready for anything yeah no preconceived
notions and I think when we made that
movie the one I love uh that Elizabeth
Moss and I did a while back you know
there was something interesting that
happened there where it was there's an
expectation about that movie being a
duplos Brothers production it was
actually the first movie that Mel fully
produced with us
um you know it's gonna be kind of a
two-hander
um and you know a lot of times we do
these movies in just a few locations and
but there was a surprise element to that
that that people really enjoyed and this
movie has something similar to it where
it once honors the tradition of making
smaller very human stories
um but kind of goes up a notch with the
high concept so how have you actually
been describing the film to friends and
family
uh the way we've been describing
biosphere is biosphere is about the last
two men on Earth uh one's a politician
and one's a scientist and they are
living in a biosphere that the
scientists built uh and they have a
self-sustaining Pond they're surviving
off of and their last fish in the pond
dies and suddenly they have to figure
out how to evolve and live
yeah it's a movie about fish
you gave me everything and nothing at
the same time I'm starting to put I'm
starting to put more together yeah okay
that fish that fish that got you
thinking no but I mean for what was it
for you I'm sure you're offered a bunch
of scripts what was it about this
project that said I need to do this oh
[ __ ] man you're gonna make me give away
stuff um
it was a very human story no
um
there's some there's some of the
surprise elements right there's one
element in particular that's sort of
like talks about the possibility and
power of magic
and how necessary it is to have hope in
the midst of seemingly a hopeless
situation I think that was really one of
the biggest draws to me because these
are the two last people on Earth and
like what keeps someone going when
there's nothing to live for unless you
think that there's something to live for
does that make sense okay that was a big
draw for me I can't talk about the other
stuff besides Mark and Mel and Zachary
or whatnot but you'll know after you
watch the movie
um every movie is a challenge to get
made talk a little bit about this was I
believe your first feature so talk a
little bit about how tough was it
first feature this is the first feature
as a director that's what I'm oh sorry I
mentioned like that I don't mean like
producer no no I I apologize the reason
the reason I brought that up though it's
important because it you know Mel has
been such a deep creative force in our
company for so many years that when
we're such a collaborative company that
I mean she has you know dare I say
helped to backseat direct even the
things that I have worked on a lot and
so this was really the first time where
you know we wanted Mel to come forward
and kind of like officially take the
reins sure we'll talk a little bit about
the obviously first
first feature director
um was this one of these things where um
because I know you've done a lot of
projects on a budget and you know how to
make the most out of a little so talk a
little bit about the challenges any
movie getting made is really tough talk
a little bit about the challenges you
ran into
I mean getting a movie made with Mark
dubos is super easy so that part was
easy uh getting it up and running
because we have this amazing team and
Company and
um I don't know that this movie was
magical you know they're like Sterling
said there was this magic around it
um it was a breeze it was no big deal my
salary was probably the most difficult
part it was tough of the whole thing
them trying to do it under budget and I
was like come on now
I mean we we did build a biosphere so
that should tell you something I mean
yeah it's not like the other super cheap
movies we were able to to make but I
think part of what made this movie work
and I'm I'm gonna say this because you
can't say it is that like Mel has given
herself fully anybody who knows in his
work with Mel has given herself fully to
everything we have made and Beyond over
the last 10 or 15 years and so when
everybody heard that Mel was going to be
directing for the first time it was like
everybody showed up with everything they
had and it was so not to be like cheesy
but it was so beautiful to be a part of
it was like everybody's like all right
whatever you need whenever you need I'm
here
exactly I'm curious what ended up being
the biggest challenge on your end to
help facilitate bringing this Vision to
life you know working with Mark and Mal
and the lady in the Dale they were my
producers and I was directing so to have
that reversal and to be able to
reinforce your vision and what you were
doing was such an incredible opportunity
to reciprocade your incredible Mastery
over your work and these two actors are
at the height of your Mastery I mean
these performances it was sincerely like
experiencing a master class and the
performances just jump off the screen
spoken like a producer like that that's
how you get that [ __ ] that's true
so every time you're making for for
everyone I'm sure you're looking at the
schedule you're looking at the script
you see all the things that you need to
get done for each of you what was the
day like the that you were most nervous
about whether it be the performance a
set a location whatever it may be what
was like the night before thing that you
were most nervous about I think we saved
it for the end yeah I mean it'll be real
obvious when you see the movie what the
answer is for all four of us but but not
talking about that one there's this
really uh fun scene you know part of the
concept of the film is these guys are
really good at sustaining themselves
inside of this this biosphere and part
of that is they get exercise so we have
this track around the biodome and they
and they run around in there you know
and we have this very long dialogue
scene an argument about Super Mario
Brothers and its Merit as it applies to
these two
um but we really wanted to try and see
if we could get this [ __ ] in one take
you know and so we have a rickshaw and
someone is running with it because you
know the Dome is only so big and I mean
that's kind of one of those things where
like yeah we were running forward and we
were getting tired but then our grip
kezra is running backwards carrying a
rickshaw with a camera person on it and
I've never really seen an athletic feat
like that on an independent film before
I haven't seen that much sweat yes yeah
I mean between each thing he's like yeah
I'm okay yeah I'm okay like this is Pat
in the market we smelled it too it's
Dome small you can smell it yeah well
those are the scenes too when we were
all locked in the bio they closed the
final wall
and left us in there that's right and it
was August in a warehouse in Glendale
Los Angeles there's more I'll talk after
the after the film after you watch I
have an individual question for you
actually because I'm curious obviously
you've been a part of this is us for
many seasons and uh and is it do you
sort of feel like because I know a lot
of actors that work on shows and it
limits how many projects you can do
because you're working so much on a show
like Morning Show you know when when
you're filming you have the six month
commitment whatever it may be this is us
as a longer commitment yeah um is it
sort of I don't want to say the word
happy that it's over but like it allows
you to take on more projects because you
are done with that commitment of your
life I think I think for a lot of actors
variety is the spice of life and being
my teacher used to refer to it as
controlled schizophrenia and like
letting different aspects of your
personality out and so I it's always
nice to be known for a body of work over
just one one character you love that one
character I'm deeply in love with my
time playing Randall or whatnot but
hopefully being able to play a few more
things and just sort of stretch it out a
little bit being known for that means
something to me so yeah it's it's nice
getting a chance to play on different
playgrounds I want to switch a little
bit to some uh other questions we're
doing this thing here called get to know
your Tiff attendee okay I promise these
are harmless but for all four of you if
you could get the financing to make
anything you want and I know you can get
films made but maybe perhaps there's
this dream project you haven't been able
to do so if you can get the financing to
make anything you want what would you
make and why someone else go first
uh the first thing that popped into my
head is I want to make more episodes of
room 104 I mean making that show what we
were able to do I just thought it was
gonna be this fun creative side project
but what we're able to do over the
course of 48 episodes in terms of giving
people opportunities in front of and
behind the camera what it did for me in
terms of juicing me up to be able to
collaborate with different people like I
was just getting to that point in my
early 40s where that's when The Yips
start settling in you know as we start
getting like complacent
um so selfishly for me that
collaborative little space like I'd make
a thousand more episodes of that right
on exactly the project I'm working on
now with HBO it's a feature or
documentary about the trans sex workers
role in the Meatpacking District in New
York and it's coming out next year I'm
not gonna say anything about a senior
and it's great is it does it take place
in like the 70s and 70s 80s 90s odds to
today it's a full history of some of the
most marginalized folks in our community
can can you say the title The stroll and
when does it come out it's going to come
out next year got it early next year I
hope
foreign
I have kind of a fascination with water
roses
I love it so much something to kind of
update I haven't quite figured out what
my my take on it is yet but when I
figure it out
[Laughter]
oh my God I don't have any answer
um I guess I guess I would build another
biodome and make the official sequel to
uh biodome biodome too
awesome
not to be confused poly ready Paulie
ready uh you heard this question
recently so you might have a different
answer or we're going to keep it but uh
for everyone else if someone has
actually never seen anything you've done
before or worked on what is the first
thing they should watch and why I made a
short film called mother comes to Venus
with Superstar Alexandra gray Jasmine
Creighton and Nikki Blanco and it is
easily accessible on the internet and 10
minutes long yes
what is it Mel for me yeah I'm not in
anything no like as a producer yeah I
mean I am like in a loving relationship
still with the movie the one I love that
Mark and I made years ago
um that was special that that was just a
beautiful magical experience also you
bought your car and we sold the movie I
bought my first car that was cool that
was cool
um God for me gotta be the league baby
um
I don't know you know weirdly the a
movie I brought to Tiff like five or six
years ago blue jay that I did with Sarah
Paulson while it's not definitive
because it's maybe not as funny as some
of the other stuff it was like the movie
where I was I kind of least guarded I
think putting something out and I I I
don't know what it is certain movies you
you have there they just get you at the
right time and place and that one is
close to me uh this is going to be I'm
going to try to word this right uh what
TV show would you love to guest star on
or guest direct or guest produce or
guest right like something that you're
obsessed with pen 15.
this is you are a good fit for that by
the way this is this is something that
can happen you just put that out in the
world yeah
learn to act and then go on succession
oh yes
I want to learn oh this is so good Logan
Roy Affair nice nice what's yours mark
god
um
I think for me I want to go back and
play like
one of the sons
of one of the ladies in The Golden Girls
in 1990. I just want to be in that world
in a very special episode with them I've
been watching that show lately
feels so good they didn't do very
special episodes
and like in the late 80s I'm like 13 or
14. you see baby I get into a little bit
of drugs
and and then like you know I gotta say
you've thought about this
listen but actually I have a script
right here who's done with you be here
oh my gosh what might be so I'm watching
Mark's brother on industry right now
which I love I love industry and I love
his turn on on the show as well is
really good I would have said I could
have said succession too but let's say
like season two I'll get my culinary
skills up put me in the bear
feeling the Bear right now [ __ ] I like
that bear it's hot yeah yeah the um for
people that have not seen the bear uh I
really recommend it's [ __ ] great
especially episode seven and pulling off
if you haven't seen it they do a Warner
in episode 7 that's the whole episode
and it's it's when you watch it it's
crazy because it's in the kitchen and
all the things that happen in the
kitchen it's it's fantastic yeah the
filmmaking is really fantastic shout out
Chris store dope dope ass show yeah um
uh what movie or movies do you think
you've seen the most
Muriel's Wedding
just a guilty pleasure
is go uh in 1984 Jay and I won a contest
where you count the candy on the screen
and if you got it right you get a free
ticket to the movie theater for a year
so Jay and I got General Cinemas full
admission pass this is why we became
filmmakers and that summer I think I saw
the Karate Kid like 37 times
minimum what do you remember how many uh
how many candies were on the screen I'm
shame to admit this but listen this is
no secret to how I work Jay and I kind
of rigged the system
um we were like all right let's go see
this movie like three or four times in
which it appears uh we brought our
friends we broke it into eight quadrants
and so we had each person count within
the eight quadrants and then we came up
with like it's got to be between like
350 and 450 and then we this is terrible
I feel terrible about this we took we
took the you know because this is like
in the 80s like it wasn't very high tech
it was just like a little piece of paper
that they had we took it we brought it
Kinko's we photocopied it and we
submitted like every five or so candies
we submitted the the thing for it and we
won surprisingly uh somehow
am I going to jail guys no no first of
all that's an amazing story and also it
probably really did impact who you are
today I tell filmmakers this all the
time I'm like listen it's great to
experience the breath of Cinema out
there do that but when you find a movie
that feels like you and that you might
be able to tell watch it 50 times and
make it a part of your DNA and that will
teach you how to write
which is why I keep repeating myself
like Mark you keep repeating yourself
but she fixes my scripts and that's why
we're here that's true I there was um
like years and years ago Mark was trying
to get me to move to LA and he was like
just come live in my pool house and I
spent like months there with one DVD and
it was When Harry Met Sally and I just
watched When Harry Met Sally for months
on repeat because there was no OTV in
the pool house yep that's good okay I I
there's a few Shawshank
Color Purple Braveheart
yeah yeah you and I are that age we're
Braveheart no dude like we're like 18 it
says Freedom yeah yeah that's it yeah
yeah [ __ ] done son I was
the fork yeah yeah
yeah it's funny though if I'm ever
flipping the channels with Shawshank
just put a fork in me that's it it's
done that's it we're gonna watch yeah no
it's Andy Dufresne
um uh is there anything that you collect
or obsess over
this is really called the get to know
your Tiff attendee I'm not messing
around I'm on a uh I got a steps
situation going on a steps counting
situation since I've
yeah it's getting real bad like if I
leave my phone like I count them on my
phone because my phone counts on you aim
for like 10 000 a day I try to get 20
000 in a day is the goal with the
exercise well with the but I take on my
phone calls while I'm walking Mel here's
this all the time
and you can't hear anything so it's
great for the business
um but I every now and then I'll like
leave my phone and I'll go walk
somewhere and I'll be like I didn't get
credit for my steps so I'll manually
enter the steps in will you because it's
getting real bad
okay collect or obsess over anybody else
got something readily I mean I love hot
sauce and uh I mean that's what I've
I've been collecting that for years but
I'm I'm trying to take a break I keep
getting bad because everybody knows this
and we I'll give you no everybody gives
me like Mark got me like a year of hot
sauce and now I'm like and I'm also like
I'm gonna grow up and be like a little
old lady with a really uncomfortable
butthole so I'm just like I gotta stop
soon is that because of the note I I
have to interrupt just real quick save
Mel's butthole wait do you watch uh hot
ones I was about to ask the same thing
yeah but I'm a vegetarian but they do a
vegan do a veggie Wing I would do it I
would I thought this is more important
when you're a vegetarian because you're
fine Yes actually the other thing I'm
obsessed with is high kicks that's
probably the one high kicks high kicks
the drums no like kicking my leg up
I'm totally seen it
you have a bag
she does yeah I just said there's two
move on
Zachary you got something
I'm a Taurus I'm an earth sign and
collect crystals rocks friends
and yeah that's uh that's all I got for
now I don't collect anything like I I'm
not I'm that dude like if I haven't used
or worn something within like three
months or whatever like I clear stuff
out like I need space never get any
regrets yeah oh can't believe I threw
that out [ __ ] no
my mom holds on the stuff when I go home
to St Louis and every once when I was
like oh I'm glad that like there's
somebody in my life that keeps stuff but
no there's nothing well the thing I
always think about the line from Fight
Club um it's uh the things you own end
up owning you yeah and it's really true
though yeah because the more it's
something that always resonates like the
heat dude you know what I'm saying that
he's gonna I gotta be able to go soon
[Applause]
we're almost out of time but I am
curious
um what TV show have you watched all the
way through more than once
that's interesting I don't think I've
watched anything more than one well let
me think about that all the way through
more than one banana what was the Nano
banana what's the Nana y'all have to go
see vanenna like poison in Spanish HBO
Max came out in 2020. Spanish about uh a
luminary trans woman who is a television
personality it's juicy it's real it's
hilarious it's heartbreaking and it's
it was the best show of 2020. okay no no
oh okay I haven't watched the whole show
but I will tell you I watched the season
finale of this show and as soon as I
finished watching it I watched it again
because I thought it was [ __ ]
fantastic and that was season one of
Dave
I've watched it I was like let me run
that [ __ ] back home again one more I was
dope
I've watched I think the one I've
watched the most is Twin Peaks which I
feel like is a very filmmaker thing to
say so I'll throw in Buffy the Vampire
Slayer and the Gilmore Girls and
Seinfeld and a lot I just I comfort
rewatch a lot of I mean everything I do
there's the TV in the background Mel
works very hard stuff I'm re-watching uh
the original staircase documentary with
my wife Katie she that was the other DVD
in your full house yeah
um and it's really fun to watch because
obviously you know the whole form of
true crime documentaries hadn't cemented
by the time this was made so it's very
slow very much a courtroom like you know
they would never allow that he said
they'd be like oh this is only four
episodes instead of the 10 or 11 that it
is but I really appreciate it for what
it is it is crazy how popular the the
the True Crime documentary true crime
stories has become it's everywhere it's
like if you've done anything it's time
for your show yeah you know this is on a
tangent but look I got to stop with you
guys I'm just going to say thank you for
indulging me with the get to know your
time
I really can't wait to see biosphere uh
and really congrats on being part of the
Toronto Film Festival this is like it's
just such a great Fest and you know I
hope you guys just really enjoy the
experience thanks a lot thank you
appreciate it man